ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno pues me presento yo soy un ser
humano
que ha nacido en un mundo en el que
pensar es algo positivo es algo que
todos pensamos que es necesario para
vivir y la mayoría de vosotros si yo os
digo que
puede ser que dejemos de pensar pues en
salir las manos a la cabeza
y os negaréis a que algo así que es tan
innato a todos nosotros puede llegar a
pasarnos
todos vosotros sois thinkers
y todos los jóvenes y los mayores pero
todavía todos nosotros somos 5 sin
embargo ella será una artificial
ella nacerá en el año 2045
y nacerá en un mundo totalmente
diferente
en un mundo en el que las máquinas
gracias a la inteligencia artificial van
a ser las que tomen las decisiones van a
ser las que mejoren el mundo
y os voy a explicar poquito a poquito
las tesis que tengo detrás de este
pensamiento
algunos de vosotros reconoceréis esto
que hay aquí es un callejero de madrid
algunos no lo conoceréis
cuando yo tenía 18 años me saqué el
carnet de conducir
y fui de las primeras del grupo de mis
amigos que se sacó el carnet de conducir
entonces yo llevaba este callejero en el
coche y llevaba siempre a mis amigos a
acabar las juergas pues siempre llevaba
a toda la serie de amigos a su casa
eso me ayudó por una parte a memorizar
todas las calles de madrid
eso no es pensar
pero además a base de llevarles iba a
manejarme por todas las calles de madrid
pensé y siempre sabía cuál era el
recorrido óptimo para llevar a todos
cuál era el orden que tenía que seguir y
cuál era las calles que tenían por las
que tenía que ir para llegar lo antes
posible a cada una de las casas
ahora
esta es mi nueva situación yo cuando
ahora cojo un coche y fijaros qué
interesante cuando ayudan a un
coche tengo al gps entonces primera cosa
que me pasa que los mayores que estáis
aquí lo entenderéis lo primero que me
casa me pasa muchas veces digo no voy a
poner el fps porque si lo pongo no voy a
pensar y entonces no quiero olvidarme de
pensar el tema binner en pensar y hacer
prácticas entonces no voy a ponerme a
gps y lo segundo que me pasa es que a
veces crítico al gps y le corrijo digo
este gps no funciona bien porque me está
diciendo un camino cuando hay otro
camino mejor
estoy pensando y aunque tengo ahí la
tecnología como pertenezco al mundo de
los pensantes todavía la represento sin
embargo ella tiene 18 años se acaba de
sacar el carné de conducir y es muy
importante que entendáis la diferencia
entre ella y yo ella no se plantea lo
que yo me planteo porque ya no conoce
otra realidad
solo conoce esta realidad que es su
nueva realidad ella no tuvo nunca un
callejero ni se manejó por las calles de
madrid teniendo que hacerlo con su
cabeza en lugar de con el gps
otro ejemplo hace muchos años queríamos
ver una película de vídeo y vamos al
blockbuster oa una tiendecita de barrio
y entonces pensábamos que público lo
habíamos visto cual me había gustado
cual me podía gustar porque podría ser
parecida cuál es la nueva realidad una
situación de este estilo
donde tenemos thinkers todavía los dos
pero muy diferentes los padres viven esa
realidad como algo diferente a lo que
han vivido y los hijos sin embargo la
reconocen como algo natural en su vida
cuál es la clave para que entendáis mi
charla
la clave para que entendáis mi charla es
que dejéis de ser quiénes sois intentéis
ser ella
un ser humano que nacerá en el 2045
donde todo será diferente
vamos para allá qué va a pasar en el
2045 en el 2045 dicen gente muy seria
que va a pasar una cosa que se denomina
una singularidad tecnológica que es una
singularidad es un concepto matemático
esta función que veis aquí tiene una
singularidad en x1 porque porque en x
igual a 1 cuando me acerco al 1 la
función sale corriendo hacia el infinito
a una velocidad infinita
pues eso es lo que va a pasar cuando nos
acerquemos al año 2045 con la velocidad
a la que cambia la tecnología que quiere
decir pues que la velocidad del cambio
va a ser tal
que tenéis que entender cómo eso va a
afectar a los niños y como ellas van a
hacer en un mundo totalmente diferente
fijaros este es un cambio de escala
fijaros ahora aquí tenemos de año 2007 a
2022 y más o menos veis que
efectivamente hay evolución tecnológica
pero más o menos a una velocidad y eso
es lo que nosotros estamos
experimentando esa sensación que tienes
que aprendes una cosa y al otro día
parece que ya no te sirve para nada
porque ha salido una cosa nueva si
cambio la escala otro poquito veis que
efectivamente todavía se ve pero qué es
lo interesante aquí que cuando miramos
al año 2045 si veis el tramo entre el
2017 yendo a 1.022 parece que no se
mueve
quiere decir que esa sensación que
nosotros tenemos ahora de cambio y
avance es nada en comparación con lo que
se nos viene
cambio de chip 2019
que tenemos en el 2019 por una parte
tenemos esta sensación que tenemos todos
los que somos un poco mayores no decir
bueno parece que tengo miedo porque
google que dicen que lo sabe todo de mí
que facebook que tal que no es normal
pero sé que esta sensación no de
inseguridad
todo esto está cambiando a él le importa
algo no absolutamente nada esto que para
nosotros que para muchos de nosotros
está roto que pena es aberrante
adelante para ellos no
y tenéis que hacer el esfuerzo de pensar
que porque para nosotros sea verdad no
significa que sea durante es otra
realidad y vamos hacia otra realidad
qué está pasando en la empresa os lo
cuento porque es otra de mis tesis una
de mis tesis es lo que me está pasando a
mí otra de mis tesis es lo que pasa en
la empresa que vivo cada día que sucede
con las empresas en el mundo del
marketing que está pasando por una parte
cuando nosotros vamos moviéndonos por
internet y navegamos cada vez que
pasamos por delante de una publicidad la
persona a la empresa que tiene esa
policía sabe que pasamos por ahí el
antes iba sabiendo un poco el recorrido
con nosotros hacemos de punta un punto
en el que vemos la publicidad cuando
luego entramos en la página web ya
entramos en la página web del anunciante
y el anunciante sabe todo lo que hacemos
en esa página web si además somos
clientes y nos identifica como cliente
que entre la página web sabe de nosotros
y compramos muchos y compramos un poco
si cambiamos de producto cosas sobre la
compra del producto y por último
pregunta una serie de compañías que
venden datos de terceros y si tiene
datos nosotros con todo eso enriquece y
sabe mucho de nosotros y hacia dónde
lleva eso pues eso lleva hacia que en
lugar de que tú veas un anuncio de
y a lo mejor dentro de tres días vayas a
comprar mi producto y te acuerdes de mi
anuncio de tele lleva el tiempo real a
la que a que las empresas puedan actuar
sus acciones de marketing en tiempo real
con las personas y qué está pasando pues
que estamos cada vez dando más
importancia a consejeros delegados de
grandes empresas para ello se empieza a
ser más importante la velocidad que la
verdad
la verdad viene
del pensamiento y la velocidad viene de
la inteligencia artificial que no deja
de ser un pensamiento
de resulta que como todo esto está en
boga por las empresas cada vez necesitan
más talento analítico y yo soy profesora
de alumnos
que los llamo analistas artificiales y
aquí tenemos un analista artificial como
son los analistas artificiales por
fijaros son personas que normalmente han
estudiado una carrera que no es
matemática es de ingeniería pero luego
hacen un máster en big data y aprenden
las técnicas de inteligencia artificial
y the machine learning entonces resulta
que yo les digo vamos a hacer un
ejercicio de predecir las ventas de
yogur
y yo como soy una 5 digo vamos a ver
pensemos para analizar las ventas de
yogur tengo que entender por qué se
venden yogures que afecta a la venta de
yogur pues la publicidad que hacen las
promociones que hacen los precios y
desarrollo mi modelo matemático pensando
porque no me entra en mi cabeza que un
chaval joven haga un modelo predictivo
de ventas de ventas sin pensar y tanto
tres o cuatro semanas
resulta que el artificial tarda tres
horas y me viene con un modelo que de
repente digo hombre es utilizado la
variable cuota de mercado para explicar
las ventas chaval qué tonto si la cuota
de mercado es una relación de las ventas
como me la utilizas de variable
explicativa de las ventas y él me dice
perdona yo tardado dos horas en hacer el
modelo y tú tres semanas vamos a
comparar cuatro y dice mejor
y cuál queréis que predice mejor
el suyo
entonces cree una página web porque
quiero conocer a los artificiales no
ella ella es nativa artificial pero hay
analistas artificiales entonces hice una
página web cincos artificios y entonces
pregunté a la gente ven entre la página
y dime todavía somos muchos más tintes
porque claro yo soy target singer
thinker vale pero hay algunos artificios
y fijaros qué cosas dicen rapidez
complejidad
me fío me fío se fían de la máquina
entonces porque pensamos
porque pensamos el ser humano ha pensado
a lo largo de su historia siempre con la
inquietud de mejorar siempre hemos
pensado porque queríamos mejorar
pero ahora las máquinas van a pensar por
nosotros
hemos evolucionado pensando
y ahora como las no vamos a dejar de
pensar como sociedad pero ya la máquina
está pensando a dónde me lleva el coche
ya netflix está pensando qué película de
cine me gusta así que se va a producir
una involución en el pensamiento
no necesariamente y para atrás vamos a
ir para adelante
pero dejando de pensar
qué va a pasar desde mi punto de vista
no vamos a dejar de pensar a cero no
vamos a ir a cero pero vamos a pensar
menos lo tengo clarísimo porque no vamos
a pensar tantas cosas que pensamos ahora
porque no la vamos a visitar porque
vamos a tener máquinas inicia la gente
pero bueno para hacer las máquinas
tendremos que pensar no expertos de
inteligencia artificial la inteligencia
artificial de verdad la buena la que
viene que beara pensamiento y no
necesitará un humano detrás
algunos me preguntaréis podemos evitarlo
no entonces habéis fallado esta charla
si alguien se pregunta podemos evitarlo
es una pregunta incorrecta porque no
tenemos que luchar por evitarlo
porque si nos ponemos en su lugar
ella van a hacer el mundo diferente en
donde las máquinas van a pensar van a
tomar muchas decisiones hacia el futuro
eso no quiere decir que ella va a dejar
de pensar ella va a pensar en otras
cosas
a lo mejor va a pensar cómo ser más
feliz como amar más
a lo mejor dejar de pensar como pensamos
solo para mejorar
a lo mejor es algo que va a ser bueno
para el mundo futuro muchas gracias
[Aplausos]